I don't know about you how many people
you see make it to 70 80 90 who are
obese I I can't think of one as you get
older all that talk is not cute no more
you cutting off ankles yeah you could
not flip everything hurts this is a
sickness it's not a sickness it is a
sickness no literally no it's not
I just want to show Albert something and
I want to show you guys something
because it's something I was on social
media I was scrolling on my social media
and I encountered something and it made
me chuckle and I want to show Abba
because I want to see if he's going to
Triple as me or if it's just me that
just think things are funny okay so uh
um all right so there was this there was
this fashion show of you know body
positive vagina I mean swim thick boom
right
right
boom Oh
all right boom
hi hi
boom
right
boom show me when you when when you see
something funny all right
boom all right
boom
did you see it
Body by the Tennessee bro
body positivity
you give me this
whose man is this
and you know what is this swim big on
his trunk
thick way it's dick
there's not a moral of the story there's
no I think I'm just gonna put it out
there
I just this is it I don't expect you to
say nothing yeah
your usual
that's fine I just want to put it out
there that [ __ ] was funny some of these
women weren't slim thick some of them
were just fat like I know you were
thinking about the black dude I really
don't care about that part I was just
like I've seen these kinds of events
that I find them cringe why is it cringe
I find a cringe it's one thing if the
leaves are thick or you know thicker
than you ever that's fine some of them
are just straight up fat like so what so
what this whole thing about like
celebrating stuff like no these people
are like killing themselves at risk for
a whole bunch of other [ __ ] I was like
no don't celebrate the same way we
shouldn't be celebrating someone who's
bone thick because they're taking a
bunch of drugs like it's stupid
this is dumb let's be honest it's dumb
this is dumb and we're just doing this
whole like complacency if they were just
like you wanted to say don't go out of
your way to make fun of people when
they're at that weight sure you want to
say don't shame people sure but this
whole like propping this up I find it so
cringe you think it's cringe absolutely
it's one of the mccringiest things it's
like no it's just this is a sickness
it's not a sickness it is a sickness no
no truly obesity is a sickness oh it's
not
there's nothing to say what you don't
think it's a sickness no it's not okay
what is it then this is the thing you
think obesity is just a thing
I know you're trolling yeah I was like
you really take me seriously no because
I'm trying to be serious but go ahead
the thing is I understand why people are
there like it's it's not people it's not
because someone is absolutely considered
obese that they're inherently not in a
good shape I understand that okay I
understand that and it's not because
that happens that it's not because
they're that we have to like you said
shame or this and that and they have to
be proud because while they're in a good
shape so that's not shame and let's not
you know it's just I understand the body
body positivity uh movement on in that
sense and then there's others there's
other senses in our underside of course
that's just like um everybody's
beautiful in there no I I cannot be I
I'm not talking I'm not gonna talk for
other people because I don't know their
business I can only talk for myself so
when people when the the body positivity
movement says everybody is beautiful and
and it's okay to be at any weight for
that's that's where I got a problem just
for me personally I cannot and I ensure
you cannot be over a certain weight or
else I am dying from what
high blood pressure cholesterol all of
that I understand where they're from is
there there is there is again like any
[ __ ] movements there is a lot of
Truth in what they say and then they hit
the pilot spot where they go overboard
and they're like uh yeah well you're
generally generalizing everything and it
makes no sense so I can't judge for
these ladies and be like yeah you're
absolutely obese or whatever maybe they
ain't got no problem I'm not the one to
judge I'm gonna talk about me I'm I can
only talk about me sure you know some
people do drugs and they're not
unhealthy or they're not losing their
lives absolutely but one of the biggest
indicators of shorter life expectancies
is being obese I'm not talking about
like based on the BMI thing probably
like actually properly obese we need to
stop this whole this whole thing like
it's fine you don't want to go out of
your way to both that's fine I'm not
going on [ __ ] girls Instagram Pages
back here so I would never do that while
aren't seeing this celebration of this
state or like oh my God pretty proud of
what what are you proud of gluttony
listen for some of you guys maybe he's
harder than that maybe he's not even
Glenny maybe he's like you have a
tremendous heart whatever you do and
your doctor says you need a gastric
bypass whatever the [ __ ] it is fine but
I'm not going to celebrate what is a
sickness yeah but if it's more I think
it's more complex than that there's some
people that have conditions like if you
take an example the pedema is a
condition that uh much more people than
we think have and that condition is that
your body amasses fat
is fat has nothing to do with you being
gluten or whatever whatnot it and it
hurts that's one of them so you have uh
it's not just you're fat and you call
this that's the thing it's just the
thing that they're trying to do okay
it's just that being fat is not equal
there's other things that that could be
there the the there's other things that
can be that can be it doesn't mean that
you're glitting or that you are eating
it in excess or whatever you can have
different conditions I do understand
where you're coming from I'm gonna Just
Disagree out right and the reason why
I'm going to disagree is there's a
reason why in Western countries
especially in places like North America
and England there's far more obesity
than anywhere else you can talk about
the exceptions you can talk about
outliers but the vast majority of the
reason why people are massively
overweight and dying from comorbidities
and different disease like that it's not
because of these diseases oh now if you
want to talk about the exception of that
I agree with that hold up you could talk
about the exceptions right you could be
like not all listen nobody's talking
about all when we're having this
conversation and if someone does have
what you're describing which is a
sickness like lipidemia or whatever I
still don't want to celebrate that you
can go through whatever you're going
through your body nobody needs to shame
you but we don't need to be out here
talking about this weight is great oh
you're beautiful at your butt it's not
it's not and at the end of the day these
are risks and so when I see these kind
of events that celebrate this stuff and
it's evidence of something sick
culturally speaking in the black
community obesity is just a thing much
more prevalent than in other communities
so sure enough when the when the when
the Rona hits guess what happens it's
decimated minority communities are
especially targeted due to high blood
pressure pre-existing conditions et
cetera stuff like that but it's not
because they're fast because you know
because it's racist or whatever yeah
obesity is not something light like in
terms of how it affects us as a general
population the outcomes are extremely
negative for most people you know I
don't know about you how many people you
see make it to 70 80 90 who are obese I
I can't think of one and those who make
it are not anymore they don't get to me
they have to change their way so they
die yeah Monique was promoting
big girls next thing she has an old bit
about skinny [ __ ] no no yeah she had
a whole bit about skinny [ __ ] when
she first started I remember Mo I
remember that and I'm gonna talk about
skinny [ __ ] and that was big right
black community again yeah about skinny
[ __ ] and stuff like that look at
Monique now you see Monique recently no
lost all that weight does she want to
live
if she want to leave
as you get older all that talk is not
cute no more you cutting off ankles yeah
you could not flip everything hurts
number everything that has yeah that's
if you have like a
diabetes insulator but it's just
everything hurts as well it's a lot of
string on your joints and [ __ ] it is I
I remember when Kobe hit I got really
really sad
partially because I knew how much was
affecting our community and that was
like a thing that was common and
you know you would see news reports of
these big ladies talking about oh I
don't give a [ __ ] we out here we here in
Florida gonna party and like three weeks
later we find out the same lady who was
on that video died from Rona right
pre-existing condition high blood
pressure whatever and it's just sad
because so many people from our
communities get removed we already deal
with enough jailing issues with enough
crime issues and all this stuff now
we're losing people to stuff that with
proper choice but you also have to
acknowledge right there's also the
societal aspect you also live in a
country where walking is much more
difficult because getting anywhere is
not encouraged like one thing I
appreciated spending time like traveling
is you get to see how other people live
other people's lifestyles are just far
more conducive to healthier living of
course there's a matter of personal
choices but anybody who's addicted
anybody who's got like serious like
impulse problems will tell you
accessibility generally is one of the
biggest issues with relapsing or making
bad choices meaning like if you are
prone to taking uh bad substances okay
not keeping them anywhere near you will
help you to stay away from them
generally speaking if you just leave
that stuff near somebody who's like
really severely addicted to me sugars or
whatever it's not gonna be good so when
you live in these neighborhoods whether
it's like shitty access to foods like
yeah it
bad outcomes I absolutely agree with the
personal choices matter in the situation
but I also think that Society can't
engineer itself to give people optimal
choices that are healthy as well our
societies are not geared towards that
and they're not geared towards walking
to work they're not geared towards
taking public transportation because a
lot of places public transportation is
unusable especially in the US listen
that is true for a lot of places walk
walk it walk
can you walk in L.A listen I live there
you can't walk there you can't walk you
can't but you can't walk in Florida
either because because the thing you
take two hours to get to work and back
you're dying on public transport that's
also unhealthy for you so me spending
time in Europe me spending time in
different places I got to see how
effective these systems are walking in
New York it's like oh my God what a
difference it makes you know I mean
you're burning a bunch of calories just
walking places walking up hills you see
old ladies over there in like Portugal
right just walking up big ass deep Hills
because they've been doing it their
whole lives certain cultural and
societal factors
encourage this kind of healthier living
right not at there's not a fast food
joint at every corner guess what now
they got bakeries they got little mom
and pop shops you wish that in a lot of
poor areas where obesity is far more
prevalent that these things were
accessible so it's not like I'm lacking
in empathy I'm not like unable to
understand how it's much more easy in
these kind of environments to become
like that I mean what are the saddest
things I'm not a lot of you was watching
I think the Life channel and seeing
these hugely fat obese parents fattening
their kids so I'm talking about these
kids already got high blood pressure by
the time they're in their teens how do
you even fix that your parents [ __ ]
you over your parents birthed you and
said [ __ ] we're gonna take you back to
the Grave before we even get there we're
gonna give you bone problems joint
problems by the time you haven't even
hit 20 so I don't lack in understanding
like sometimes the stuff around you
really makes it harder yeah okay and
it's not easy I'm not saying that what
I'm saying is we don't have to
exacerbate the issue by telling people
oh my God this is so beautiful oh we
don't have to do that we can say it's
okay to love yourself it's okay to say
you want better for yourself and that
you're okay with where you are but
you're gonna get better because it takes
a long time it's a long journey for
people okay weight loss doesn't have to
be a three-month thing it could be three
four five years
but I just I dislike this kind of like
as you are you're really good I was like
no no no
that's not the case when you say that
when you say that the Western world is
there's more fat people and everything
and stuff I get that yeah you're
absolutely right I'm not disputing that
at all I understand what you're saying
so we actually agree on that I'm just
saying yeah there's exceptions now that
being said when people say you're at
risk you have to understand as well that
I'm just really understanding both sides
right when
people's I think that when people say
you're at risk of if you're in that
predicament it just doesn't
automatically means that you're gonna
have that but you are in a higher risk
of having
XYZ high blood pressure name it you're
at risk it's a risk it doesn't matter
that doesn't mean that you're
automatically automatically have it but
you are at risk you are so that I think
that whenever people hear the at risk
the the bypass the at risk and the
automatically thing yeah you just told
me that I ABS absolutely did they speak
in absolute so again I I do agree with
you
maybe this is more so just
um something I notice when these
conversations unfold what happened I
noticed that whenever the points of like
obesity super rampant the first thing
they'll reply you'll hear is like all
right well you know just because people
on the BMI scale Oprah represent doesn't
mean they're sure oh well you know what
some people have conditions that need
gastric sure it feels like everything is
always just deviating from the main
point which is like yeah we're just too
[ __ ] unhealthy you want to talk about
all these outliers that's fine I just I
just noticed like
this is brought up and it's immediately
like well you know some people are sick
because listen most people are just sick
because they're fat and they make bad
choices that's the truth either they
inherited those bad choices from their
parents maybe it's a mixture of genetics
as well let's do this most people are
just fat let's just focus on that the
people who have a different issue let
them go to a different conversation but
most people are just fat because bad
choices once we can get past that and
just move past that not to be like mad
at folks but just to say like yo this is
bad not only for the individuals
involved but for society as whole how do
we make things better now folks are
gonna say well the antidote is body
positivity I don't know if that's true
let's talk about Solutions I do not
believe that when I see body positivity
in the way that it's exemplified in
these kinds of fashion shows I think uh
is encouraging people to get healthy
however I will say that when folks just
go out of their way to shame people and
yell at them that's not helping either
okay I don't think you got to go to
somebody's obese and yell at them or
shame them now some folks are going to
reply and say oh
I
was shamed and it helped me maybe it
worked for you maybe you're but that's
not necessary that's not most people
okay most people so you give them
negative stimuli sometimes they just
Retreat from it they don't all need the
same kind of treatment and so if we're
just thinking about what's best as a
solution for people yeah I would say
that you are respectful people but you
also don't go around encouraging it or
going yes Queen when they say they're
fat and they've been eating Twinkies all
day where the [ __ ] poor choices or
exercise choices they've been making
just because it doesn't mean I'm at risk
should scare you
it should frighten you I don't know what
else to tell you walking into putting
your head in a microwave
not good for you
oh actually only puts you at risk for
yeah okay sure it's not good for you get
that through your head it puts you at
risk for a lot of issues if you just
stick your head in the microwave and
turn that [ __ ] on for three hours that
was a heart about 12 for myself
at some point when I was not good you
know I mean you're like oh [ __ ] I'm I'm
actually not good and and it's it's
really like a hit it's really a hit in
the face when
doctor
when the numbers are there and they show
you that [ __ ] you're gonna die if you
like doing like this keep doing you but
if you do
you're gonna be a whole rapper down at
50. yeah
it really hurts and sometimes you think
people are doing that because
yo they don't have to hurt me or these
things are mean things but no sometimes
it's actually the opposite you say
something because you are concerned and
you want the best for friends you want
the best for the people around you one
of the best you want the best for your
homies and [ __ ] and people really take
it personal
the thing in life whenever you have a
disagreement with someone
don't assume and that's what we often do
don't assume that the person is mean
that's something that I either don't
know or they want your good after that
assume that they want to get you out but
it's not often not the case the person
doesn't want to [ __ ]
they don't want necessarily to take you
out or Diss you or whatever or not it
just hurts
and the truth hurts sometimes